[Musique]
c'est la rencontre de deux mondes le
jazz et le hip hop la harpe et la danse
avec une between isabelle olivier ifrad
ya font tomber des barrières à l'origine
un album de la musicienne sur son séjour
outre atlantique
je me suis installé à chicago il ya six
ans et de d'expérimenter cette page
blanche quand on arrive dans un pays
qu'on connaît personne
on n'a pas le droit de travailler
comment construit un projet artistique
et que effectivement quand on est de
deux continents différents on est
vraiment différent en ce qui concerne la
lisière ça fait écho à l'entre-deux
c'est un petit peu une situation dans
laquelle je me suis retrouvée de parme a
donc mes racines bien sûr de je suis de
nationalité française mais d'origines
multiples et je me suis retrouvé
d'emblée dans une forme d'entre eux deux
un entre deux espagnols et mauritaniens
dans lequel il fera dia puis sa matière
chorégraphique isabelle olivier se
nourrit de ces expériences
internationales se rencontrent il ya
plus d'un an
la curiosité puisque aller au centre de
ma démarche en tant que danseur et
chorégraphe c'est-à-dire lé jeu
j'affectionne de vous confronter à des
univers différents des écritures des
dépenses est différente
une rencontre un duo qui se développe
pour in between trois autres musiciens
rejoigne le plateau qu'on a mille et une
facettes
dans ce spectacle il ya des liens qui ce
qui se construit au fur et à mesure des
jours de répétition entre chaque
musicien et y fera entre des groupes de
musiciens et y fera et je crois que les
mille et une facettes apparaissent au
fur et à mesure du spectacle et que le
le spectateur voyage dans un univers qui
n'est ni de la danse ni de la musique
mais un univers presque extraterrestre
on perd ses repères en fait une
discussion entre deux arts qui
deviennent universelles les artistes
souhaitant mener des spectateurs en
voyage un appel au partage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]